j'aurais tout revienne sur ce qui s'est
passé avec jean luc reichmann jean luc
reichmann qui a été la cible de grosses
rumeurs le feu le magazine france mag a
révélé que l'animateur des 12 coups de
midi été placé dans le coma évidemment
ces rumeurs étaient fausses il a préféré
y répondre avec humour sur son tik tok
regardez jean luc reichmann placé dans
le coma bon bon sens encore bon ça c'est
encore c'est encore meilleur jour une
dame au
jeu et l'a donc terrible accident
protocole d'accord mais jean luc
reichmann effectivement là de là il
affiche toujours un sourire à toute
épreuve théo utt on ut et ben ça non
alors le clos ma oui mais les fautes
d'orthographe
non voilà alors jean-luc voilà c'est
quoi cette histoire de coma le pousse
dans le bon ou mon ami pas et c'est ça
un truc qui écoutent totalement faux
alors s'il faut ça c'est que franz mack
c'est une copie de france dimanche nous
ne nous apprend ce dimanche oui france
d'igor france dimanche qui est
l'original des magazines people de ce
type là alors comme vous pouvez le voir
blanc vous n'avez pas de la totalité des
choses mais la maquette est totalement
copiée sur celle de france dimanche
d'accord et c'est en fait c'était quoi
leur ticket pour eux il était pas du
tout comment ils étaient coiffés mais en
fait moi je réclame un peu d'indulgence
pour ces presse en fait il a été placé
dans le coma il ya très longtemps quand
il est déjà avait à la suite d'un
accident lors culation et donc il faut
une sorte de résurgence de sa ra
contrôler c'est terrible il avait failli
avant de perdre la vie en étant dans le
coma d'humour et jean luc reichmann je
trouve vraiment des classes